okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are at the very tail end
of functionality for version 12.04 from
language we haven't been doing very many
live students recently because basically
we're just squashing bugs or people are
just squashing bugs and I'm working on
some other things and we will be
restarting lots of exciting new stuff as
soon as twelve o is out the door but
right now we're just dealing with the
tail end of twelve oh and part of that
tail is documentation is I thought we'd
finish this but apparently not um
remaining documentation for the database
integration project
so looks like aggregated entity class is
the thing that we have to talk about
here right and what part of this have we
not discussed you wanted to see more
examples okay uh review these vids are
no but yeah Nene you wanted to see are
already reviewed and finished we think
yes yeah I also brought the updates of
each function that you have notes with
you it's good I'm sorry what do you mean
well Oh
okay
I remember that last time we talked
about this there was a question of what
to hold the function that does the
aggregation and I think that in group by
is called the combiner okay let's take a
look here so this this we have gone over
represents an XI class containing a
single entity
what this thing G prop
no it's the first one it's the F in the
second argument that are the miners all
right so
you
well what happens if I just say okay so
hold on here
you
okay so that does nothing until we
resolve with
understand why I have to repeat total
area 17 times to just fantastic what the
hell's that what is that
guys I have no idea looks like a
quantity frame doctor or the test
appeared before yeah well so it needs to
be nailed down um okay so let's look at
what this is why is it an aggregated
entity class why does that I mean when
it says represents an entity class
containing so so the only thing I can
ask about here is total area well that's
one in that case yes but of course if
you are if you ever miss the rules in
the second argument and you have a third
argument then you can have a bunch more
stuff so you can group by elements by
period and then compute all sorts of you
know max mean and what is the thing that
is being fed in here the e that's being
fed in here
what is this I don't understand okay so
that's that's the okay that gets fed the
groups but I understand that this the
group can't have an area here it's
effectively an association that has
certain keys in this case property
values that are lists that you then can
aggregate I'm not buying this I don't
understand this seems like a hat what is
e let's imagine that I just say you know
echo see our temporary entity classes
that corresponds to the things that are
being grouped so if the third argument
in that case
interesting what did you happen here
what did it do what happened here no
idea and this is Tony's implementation
but Tony shouldn't this have worked yes
and what would you expect it to a bad
code it should have a code an
association so the Christmas better that
should work or not probably yes but
that's not an association that's the
whole entity class of all countries in
fact it's not really a class it can't be
a class I don't have time what it is
I don't know you think about it as as
the class of all countries if you ask
the area of the customer countries you
get out of list of values and so in that
sense it is the class look I don't care
what sense it is I you know what is the
e that is this entity function usually
is a function being applied to entities
where E is an entity you know they are
two two ways you can answer that what it
is philosophically and what it is
practically philosophically it's a new
kind of intermediate entity it's an
association because you can view an
entity it's an association basically as
its property Association yeah okay so is
this the only function is this the only
case in the system where entity function
doesn't take an entity as its as its
formal vary but it takes a class and
there are other cases where any function
takes class it takes a transposed class
really no no no no no no listen listen
listen entity function in its
documentation and everything says it is
being fed entities correct yes
single form a single form parameter
block it says that it's used like Ramsey
problem but yeah it binds but it says in
the details that in the case of an
agreed on the class it doesn't bind to
an end
you
I mean we've had discussion the last
time the thing is that the same as
function it doesn't really know what it
binds to oh I see the reason this
doesn't work is because echo is not one
of those supported functions and it's
just silently failing is that correct
that's ankle echoed should work with the
memory entities sorry with built-ins
because this is happening client-side so
it's only on the databases that those
are the only functions our support
you
you
you
is that true for all sql's this list
they think that least yes we did we have
a problem with drag acts in MySQL we
have to yeah relax support yes I'm sorry
what do you think that the Reg axia
should be improved because some database
is supporting only lifestyle operations
and also like we should be able to dance
to transform like I want to know why I'm
sorry sorry now we're just saying that
you know in a scale when you're doing
full text at shorter things like that if
you use the like operator say only the
phone you just can say the following
forms can be compiled to SQL because
there might be other ones that can be
compiled right not at this moment
and once we add them we'll add them also
in the documentation okay what are we
trying to resolve in this meeting I
sufficiently out of context it's been
several weeks since we met I'm I'm not
sure what um this have I gone through
every word that's in here so far yes
okay so what did we want to look at
again here so in this one who wanted
more examples and there are more
examples now there will be even more
soul you know what you can't have an
example that doesn't even have any text
here come on that might be my fault I
communities are new changes
there was a conflict in CVS
four elements in each period in the in
the periodic table for each period class
and this here would be this is the total
MS find no it's not the total landmass
it's the total area yet of land area
it's not there's a separate property
called land area yeah but it doesn't
include ocean statuary it yes but it
includes Lakes so don't say land area
you
you
um you know what this is
incomprehensible I mean in other words
okay aggregate create
an aggregated entity class how to
explain this
um create an aggregation of the total
areas of all countries then extract the
total area I don't know it's somewhat
confusing but whatever
maybe this out the first total no no no
because the aggregation okay
create an aggregation by computing the
total area yes who is he
creating a grid
of all countries and competitive area
whatever find the average population
what are we gonna do with the missing
yeah we remove we that's why that that
example we substituted with the area
because the missing it's not treated
probably well how should the messing be
treated but I think in this case as if
you're doing total as zero somebody on a
live stream is saying this functionality
is ugly I could not agree more
it's disgusting but it's basically a
wrapper around SQL I mean this is a
completely stupid way to compute this
result how would we compute it in a
sensible way we just say total of um
right we just say that oh my goodness
sake what is going on here but that
should work right but that does work but
I mean if you do that from something
which is very large databases then it's
just gonna stream a huge amount of data
choked up your memory and sure this is
the optimization for the fancy people I
mean this is what anybody ordinary would
do
suitable for small baby that's going
into basic examples what sir
yes it should because people won't
understand what's going on they'll look
at this and they'll say why the hell
would I do that by the way you're gonna
have to run this from this bug is fixed
I mean also this is unnecessarily
complicated right I mean it could just
say yeah yeah but there's examples later
where we have a shorter form so for
example total the one we problem on the
payments below is much shorter
why not the short form first because the
short form is kind of an abuse of
notation and that's as the first example
should be the first usage message I
think and it's true lights down it's
there it's not out there okay what do
you want me to look at here I mean I
think this is unbelievably complicated
as a user has said here and you know
it's great if you're doing large-scale
stuff with big SQL databases ok what
should we be looking at here what was
the point of this meeting we mostly you
have to review all the existing like
entity entity property entity list until
you function all of those you ever took
that at all this one you just had a
complaint that they're working at for
examples ok
what when do we call it a complex single
entity when do we use that term nowhere
yes
okay so why isn't it looking like this
why doesn't it look exactly like this
but the reason is that so it is complex
in the sense that you could have say you
take it if the first argument is say g8
and the second argument is Portugal and
that that empty doesn't exist because g8
is not important towards your point I
mean selector is the so is a name no
that's always a name that's the
canonical name but the thing is that it
represents in the sense of SQL you were
performing complicated query and then
you're selecting one row that clear so
in that sense it's complex in since it's
not one of the bays entity types that
come with whatever you registered or
whatever is possible so it could be like
combined entity so this we don't want to
say this we don't want to say it like
that because that's a named class right
so what this represents there that could
be a combined NT class and we did it
doesn't want to be a named entity it's
it's a okay represents an entity
from the computed class represented by
specified by C spec there works
oh for God's sake not this bug again our
office well we reported that bug and it
was ignored apparently okay let's get
Brian on the on the call please to do
that thank you kind of amusing and what
it did I suppose
on the livestream is saying that all the
stuff needs more elaborate documentation
and I couldn't agree more I mean I
assume that you guys are making a one of
these tech notes or tutorials I mean not
tutorials monographs yeah looks about
the stuff what's the state of that well
it's closer to the beginning still but
it's I am going to accelerate on that in
the next phase okay yeah Ethan our live
stream is encouraging the examples that
show why the things this I don't think
that's really possible in me I mean I
think that's what we're trying to do
here
yeah that monograph will contain
examples that will illustrate why these
constructs are useful which can be much
better seen on more complex queries
where all things become entangled and I
think this if Ethan on a live stream is
confused about what's going on here
these are native queries in SQL that's
the whole point
yeah the the the this is not there's not
something where we're doing it this
thing here is not a native query because
it's not on something which needs to be
in SQL but everything else here that's a
native query that's happening at the
speed that Postgres it's it's happening
through Postgres or whatever thing is
managing that relational database yeah
but also the other thing here is that
this layer on top of SQL isn't trivial
because it transforms the thinking mode
from SQL to functional because we have
compositional and functional blocks in
here why LS key all is different you
know and the composition in SQL is
different so that's why it's useful
right well and also this is in fact a
lot cleaner in the end because what this
and we should show somewhere what this
turns into as an SQL query
how do you get that out again well the
actual query was uh last time you asked
to contribute a function to function
repository that would do that we also
talked about having this separate
property entity value that will be
called SQL string but I'm not sure
whether it was decided to have it or not
I think we could have it I don't think
that would be harmful that will be by
far the easiest way I guess to it but I
mean it and that will be an SQL string
specific to so so how would I extract
that SQL string for this for example can
I see the value of whatever query you
have no no I'm asking something it
actually works right now you must have
an internal function that does that we
do but there's a bug there whatever that
is I'm not sure that I'm ready to tell
you what it is right away I'm sorry but
we will certainly flesh this out and
make it work very very yeah I mean I
think that the way it should work is
like with the third argument when you
value and that could be SQL string and
if it's applicable and you let this go
stream that makes sense that makes sense
so it's like extracting the data set
yeah hey Brian um young something is
very wrong with docu tools do I need to
update my doggy tools or something
because they're making just a total mess
I this email that you sent a few years
ago yep that was what I got when I when
I when I did an intensive on that cell
up in the usage looks like it's the same
thing you saw those bugs where the
12-plus thing is you know infecting
pieces of the actual text I think so
yeah um I'll talk to Jay and we'll get
this fixed I I know I don't think
and I don't think an updates gonna help
you here I think I'm competitive Inge up
there has been that we usually refer
usually usually supposed to use the mod
info buttons like the f2 you know the
bright pink F up there makes it future
the the fact of future izing and
tentative Inge works up there at always
kind of an later edition um but we can
make it work all right okay no problem
okay thanks did you need something else
from me nope no right that was it thanks
Larry bye okay um by the way if you get
a lump of SQL code what can you do with
it I mean can you literally just put it
in to some you know just feed it into a
database or should we have some embed
code type thing that gives you wrapper
stuff for it we need something like that
yes well that depends because so the
thing is that there is a common thing
that is done is that you get the SQL
string with placeholders for parameters
and then you get the parameters
separately that's very common okay well
maybe we can do that with an embed code
thing with it which emits a string
template now I'd like to see this SQL
code could you figure out what the
internal function is that you call to
get it yeah I forgive me like 5-10
minutes all right
in the meantime we can look at the
tentative ice details there no we need
to we need to any - we need to okay
possible in stubs is that really true
and to do
open/close gives oops gives you a bunch
of these types
yes--that's since the beginning and the
reason was we have our fractions that
return a list of the entities an entity
value is one level above so it gives the
list of types okay so this is a bad idea
okay we should not we should not
describe this bad idea but what we
should do instead is since we now have
entity pages right um is on this page we
should link to the list of entities
entity types okay so that requires and
that's something andraia that's
something for you for um I'm doing an
entity page knitting session with Alan
at 8:30 tonight um something we're gonna
need is a landing page for all entities
under I do you understand I'm saying yes
to see okay so let me explain what what
that's related to again and what we're
gonna need to to set up okay so if I go
to import here Oh for godsake
what is wrong with this whatever
something has been really broken okay so
you see that thing that says listing of
formats yes okay so what we want to add
here is something that says listing of
basic entity types actually we don't
even need to say that let's just say
listing of entity types all right so
what you need to do is figure out how
that gets done and that's a Brian
question and then we need to point that
to a page that Allen and I need to
create which is that top-level listing
of entity types did you understand what
I'm saying yes do you plan to do that
tonight
everything yes yes we can do that but
then then this has to be linked by Brian
in the same way that the import
export thing was linked okay okay um in
fact you could warn Alan that we're
gonna do this and what it's for but it's
a link from this page okay can I please
say something yeah okay imagine if you
think of so anti value takes two
argument and this takes one argument and
then the listing of all types is the
zero argument continuation of this you
know what so I don't know the problem is
that empty list is a separate function
but if an entity value of a class return
the list of entities then this would
kind of I don't care it doesn't it's
just not something it's not a piece of
functionality but I think you know what
what good is going to come of having
that list well if you have that list
then you can map or need entity count
for example to figure out which is the
type that has the most entities
I don't want who cares you might care
but I don't think anybody legitimately
cares about that import formats like
export formats I know but it's different
and it has a lot of cruddy stuff in it
right but we don't really want to expose
to people I mean there's a lot of crazy
stuff here what is a yoga prop nobody
here some some kind of thing about the
break stuff like that so when you're
already I can paste the code that needs
to be executed to switch on this is the
craziest stuffs we have okay whatever
weird stuff and this list is about to
get a great deal longer but there's one
that's like food cross
something and what's this
these are entity types that have been
dynamically added here right yeah
because just register them I I would
prefer to just not list the seer I would
prefer to just not say that okay let's
look at and so on this listing of entity
types what we want to do is to okay what
do you want to show Leonard can you
gonna send me something or do I have to
look on your screen oh no no I'll Sun
you it's just good single line that you
just send me oh yeah and then if you
execute any example in the database
you'll see the query printed in addition
to the result right this is not how we
want it to really be yeah yeah I
understand but since you want it now to
have some way this is the easiest right
now okay all right so now this is the
aggregated whatever whatever thing here
okay that was pretty trivial in SQL
show me something which won't be as
trivial in SQL oh okay I will just paste
it in here this is slightly less trivial
but also in all these examples here in
the documentation pages for separate
functions most of them in terms of SQL
will be rather trivial right and by the
way you should give some examples here
under properties and relations probably
for how this relates to the SQL stuff
okay you mean on a separate funding for
each separate function yeah it this
function we should show what the SQL for
this function basically is yeah okay
sure umm oh for goodness sake well it's
nice that somebody pointed out that this
here this is dumb and we should remove
it I look dumb
you
why is this even relevant
function I'm gonna remove this it's not
even accurate anymore
there's no food crust in here
there are other examples here of these
computed periscope
that's a really shitty example if I
might say so I mean this originally
class thing looks pointless no but I
think the point of this example has been
to show that you can get useful
information from entities with the you
know of this new class that has been
computed so these entities they like
they didn't exist before and they
contain user information such as a total
or average population in this case and
you can still pick a single entity and
get out this useful value so it's not an
entity of a base class you know why you
know what is this what the heck is this
that's not something I added something
that can be removed that was an early
design
okay so what does this do what is this
what is the correct statement for this
okay this shouldn't be as high up as
this okay so all of this stuff is about
registered types is that true
I mean or non not from a computed class
right that right everything here depends
for example the identifier name is jeri
string but for certain types can be a
lists and integers that's also for
computed types also yeah I mean if the
if the entity still has a label even if
it's complex then those things about
this Rishon form under standard form are
true okay but it comes from the label
one oh by the way that thing that you
four tries to 12-plus is actually being
true since the beginning of times this
is almost certainly going to fail if I
try and try and change that
hmm actually worked um okay let's just
try to understand oh boy where do we say
okay and implicitly defined entity
we're not even documenting that in the
main I'm totally confused this isn't
really correct cuz we really want people
to use implicit we'll define an entity
classes not and plus to define entities
right which is probably why this is so
low in this see I think we should just
remove it but for things like food they
still exist right one still exists the
implicit entities I don't know Tony can
you speak to that please but they're
different use cases sometimes you want
an average entity like in the case of
food and sometimes you want the class of
entities and for each other but we're in
this documentation does it show me how
to do implicit entity classes I'm
wondering whether that disappeared
because I remember it being there no but
this is about the entity not entity
classes yes so why should it still and
why should it go tell about the implicit
entity classes on this page because
apparently there are also implicit
entities yeah but that's a different
thing
okay Tony what is the stuff down here
mean I'm implicitly define density we
don't say anything about what the
implicitly defined entities are there
should be a usage line what would it say
he says it pretty well so we actually
want a line like this correct is that
correct yes but there's a difference so
the way that the properties are chose
but the entities are chosen is the same
but then the properties are aggregated
with a certain default aggregate
function for that property okay okay so
we in fact need something else here
right we need something which says
basically this right all of this needs
to be here how do we not have this here
what this is really weird because that I
think you wanted to deprecate them they
basically don't make much sense outside
of food no they're average properties
right is that true or is that not true
yes but for a lot of things it's not
really defined and you know there's this
whole extensive intensive thing I mean
it's the supports why scatter what are
you talking about every property has has
this kind of aggregator and by the way
you got to get hold of Brian again
because we need to actually be able to
enter this stuff okay this is stupid
stupid what's here is not adequate right
and by the way is this correct entity of
type is sometimes used to represent
generic entity of the specified type
likely to represent an entity type
no but don't we have nope where is it
doing that for instance types can have
type information for instance the type
can have a singular and a plural label
attached to it okay do you give an
example of that okay look look first of
all does this in fact make sense
represents an average density whose
members specify conditions on their
property that would be more precise what
an average entity is of course
constructed from some entities that you
start with and then you average over
them
no that's nonsense
imagine for instance food in which a
hundred items but you don't want to talk
about a specific one but instead of the
class of those foods averaged over the
individual items give me an example to
send me an example of this is there any
example here okay I just don't
understand whoever wrote this doesn't
know how to write documentation why
aren't there separators here
like what what's going on here okay
Karla oh no it's it's Andrea who's here
okay okay who wrote this documentation
is anybody know Tony will you did you do
this
well maybe Nick was involved too who
first started I really don't want to
have to rewrite the whole thing so has
nothing to do with I mean it's just like
okay can we make sure if to follow
through on all other pages to make the
similar kinds of fixes yeah this was
these fish is there because you haven't
look at it no no no no this is old stuff
this is not stuff that was recently
added yeah yes um can you get somebody
other than me to look at this I really
don't wanna have to go through all of
this maybe Michael can look at this
stuff this really looks bad honestly
this really should be totally redone
it's really stupid I'm sorry I mean it's
just like like doesn't whoever wrote
this no certainly Nick knows how to
write this documentation what is this
this is just dumb
okay this unfortunately all needs to be
rewritten I really don't want to do it
okay tango scheduled a meeting with my
culture this is really dumb this is
don't look at this this is dumb it
doesn't make any sense why would you do
it this way why don't you just start off
with entity country United States why
would anybody yak on about standard form
I'll [ __ ] mistake
well that needs to be fixed when this is
not broken okay
did you understand do you understand yes
understand are you sure
right that's obviously broken right okay
do you understand that that's broken Yes
No maybe yes
okay now how are you going to get it see
if we can I'll just paste in something
from an earlier version because I don't
trust you guys to not get this wrong
come on
this is really remarkably bad
documentation Andrea could you find out
who put it in so we know can you go back
to CBS and go figure out if you can let
me know in a couple of minutes that
would be really helpful okay
brian is here with us um basically [ __ ]
tools is totally what the heck what the
heck is going on here Tony what do you
know about this is this some pact
Update that's broken everything well I
don't know
let's go tell them Nick please can
somebody get hold of Nick yes so the
entity documentation
initially written by opened it seems Wow
weird
it is started so that that's relevant
that's irrelevant um okay now okay so
this this needs a complete rewrite so
maybe Tony are you the right person to
do this or who's the right person to do
this are you gonna get all the crusty
stuff out okay let's go back up okay so
basically if I copy paste this I just
get garbage Brian
the I copy the whole box sir no I'm
copying that piece I based it here I get
absolute garbage so um copy the whole
box there like a drag then just select
the whole in line self not just to Texas
in there so like put the cursor to the
right you know I've done this a zillion
times there is a new bug we'll try and
triple click the entity class on the
right side I mean because you're copying
a an entire bunch of boxes into an
existing in line so I know I've done
this gazillion times okay that worked
well okay all right well thanks that
that I'm pretty sure this was working
before and somehow was more robust okay
but anyway we start with Thole okay all
right well thanks Brian well let me know
if you need me again okay all right um
okay so what is this guy's it's an eye
entity of the member entities and the
member entities are defined by
specifically the conditions on the
properties
can you tell who wrote the basic
examples and they're those I already
explicit the ones that wrote examples
one of them also say a said per Michael
taught what he was not the user that
updated no no I understand those basic
examples who wrote those okay let me
check your frequency
who is adam gee I don't know okay um all
right so what are we doing with this
case guys what are we doing with the
case haven't I
so we just deleting this or not we could
we're either putting that up there or
we're deleting this here Tony do people
need this or not yes it's there it's
neither for the food framework okay then
give me an example I asked you for an
example of where this is or banana ok
you want to type control equal control
equal what banana for instance
and then in the assumptions choose a
food type
give me a more real example where it
isn't just a minute where it doesn't
just say it's a food type contains
exactly banana I think or Andrew would
better know about food in particular
okay then you can do things like
hamburger with fries yeah you get added
fruit types
what the heck is that
that was crazy
do we need to document this or can this
just be an output for food the perhaps
eventually we'll do a different in a
different way Tony there's no that seems
reasonable we can redefine all of those
entities in terms of the new aggregated
entity class functionality then let's do
it this just seems super confusing oh
gosh look at this
it only works for food come on guys
I was in the example to chat
you sent a disaster example where this
where the segregate identity thing
doesn't work right no no it's implicitly
defined entity I mean I think that for
some properties we should just be loud
and instead sometimes I make here I am
now forgetting why I think we wanted to
talk to you because we thought you had
written examples for entity did you yeah
you did apparently ages ago and I was
complaining about the examples the
initial examples which I have now
completely removed okay do you remember
writing those examples or dessert enough
nothing to do with you
oh no I know what the question I'm sorry
I'm sorry I have a completely different
question
um something is wrong with my build yeah
it looks like this is this is now an
eleven point three so this is some kind
of Packard update that made this fail
that's weird the two meters would work
but oh look at that that look no you
know I go over here I saw on the entity
page you had one that was doing there
well this is a different version okay
what's going on there how you know it's
doing that if the if it's failing for
some reason to load the units resources
so that other notebook that's version
twelve this is version twelve year this
is the currently current release well
let's see what messages said record is
there possible yeah there's the there's
a Pacolet and you could try restarting
the kernel to see I'm wondering if
the taki tools messages they're
suggesting that maybe it was interrupted
loading no hmm
if you do rebuild Pacolet data and then
quit give a Pike title of what of
nothing so it that'll just refresh the
peclet resources for all the installed
packets okay that's weird
okay you need okay and again I don't
know what the status of the meeting is
here I can give you a couple there
things to debug or I can I really could
could you get hold of Roger and see
whether you guys can reproduce this okay
um because I gotta move on here okay
um you could yeah and then pull back in
here if you can okay yeah will do okay
this is not how we say this um this is
just this is really bad what's here
shoot this is really bad - okay how much
stuff do we have - I I'm not gonna have
time right now have I seen this or not
yes so you wrote this but I haven't read
it yet that correct I think no I think
you're rather tasty usage messages of
this
no no no come on get rid of all this
junk from here
actually this stuff here applies only to
built-in entity types correct or not
correct not correct okay but then so it
doesn't so it wouldn't be type it would
just be entity of spec right no it would
be spec right yeah but it wouldn't be
type it wouldn't be quote to type I'm
telling it can be see spec instead of a
price right right right right right
without the wrapping entity can just be
see spec on its own inside the entity
value yep all right let's start
rewriting this whole thing represents an
entity of this
I'd type identified by name um
represents an entity okay um well it's
not just entity expression it's the
whole thing right the sensitive value
thing the complete entity value thing
can be specified using control equals
yes this is really this when was this
written was this written like ten years
ago or something how do we usually say
that and by the way why on earth does
this not say um um
can somebody find out how we usually say
that now Tony could you go find that out
please examples I don't know I mean I do
okay listen I'm gonna have to go in a
few minutes so I don't know what how we
want to do this um this is really not
good because we you know we're still not
finished with this and we're kind of
running out of time here I can schedule
a meeting with Michael to review these
all symbols under documentation when is
Michael back tomorrow I think that's
what should happen yes um all right I'll
get I'll try and get this a little bit
further and then it's got to be there
Michael's got a look at it okay um this
is garbage
come on guys Oh
interpreter as well there nope I've
thought about that I don't think it's
the right thing to do um because we can
with hopefully this points to Interpol
papa papa
crazy crazy doesn't want to interpreter
and that certainly should be in
properties in relations let's get rid of
these okay from here Tony yes all of
this junk just let's get rid of it all
that stuff there
I'll tantalize it properties and
relations here
interpreter can return entity can we get
this
okay I'm supposed to
natural languages in control equals and
that expressions for non-standard form
using print form of entity name format
and so when possible because doesn't
this doesn't always have a name it could
be the CE spec entity right what would
it do then if it has a defined label it
uses that otherwise it falls back to
name that means the canonical name no
I'm talking about when it has some
complicated aggregated thing it won't do
anything will give no formatting wanted
as a matter of fact there is the first
example in scope shows the new
formatting okay this is irrelevant
we shouldn't even talk about that here
but what we should do in this case is
what is the name of the thing that says
um the cashing thing what is it called
ah general I'm talking about the thing
that cashes next function that caches
prefix what is it called entity prefetch
and the
and to prefetch okay um
represents a registered entity type
correct if you mean
entity types yeah I mean either one all
registered entity type is this really
true is just the print form string I
think we should get to these summer um
way down at the bottom
ah okay the answer to type okay um you
don't say it's a string it says double
quotes um
can be either a built in and be either a
built in entity type or a type
registered with entity register correct
yes do we link to entity register here
apparently
what does entity type name do in the
case of an entity so with a composite
entity this identity is still true right
it's a problem when it's combined entity
class because there's no unique type I'm
not just asking is this identity true
identity type name of entity of first
argument blah right that's true it's
just a list of all first yeah yeah yeah
I understand I understand yeah but it's
I think the rel T type name is I mean
the way it works right now is rather I
mean it won't cut it for the new types
of classes so you need to figure out
what to do with this look let's come
back to this here okay so the question
here is named is it is this right this
correct this line here yes because there
are certain infinite families of
entities that stock it fine property
values of an entity properties I
of an entity can be computed using now
is that correct that it has to be
string or an entity property expression
is that correct yes and now also entity
function string an entity property
expression or and
function expression okay in this okay
let's hope that this doesn't break this
thing hope this doesn't mess this up
amazing okay can be any of the following
its that brace doing them don't we want
to say what these are I understand how
you can have a name if you've got some
complicated composite entities structure
how does a name refer to something in
that it's less a name as more syntax for
indexing into that new table well so
give me an example
oh but sometimes it's a name for example
we can do aggregated entity clause
okay so in this case the name we just
wrote that the name is a string an
entity right okay but that's not true in
this case right here's an entity class
as the name right it can be an arbitrary
expression now so what we wrote here is
not correct
right
that line is correct for the string type
if if you have a general C spec in the
first argument then we might want to
explain the algebra that relates the
first argument to the second argument
yeah but I still don't understand why I
would say anything like that about what
name is because it could be that you
have a database where you know the
primary key is timestamp so those will
be date objects it could be that it is
some sort of u8 year for some reason it
gets important despite already you said
there's no point in saying what this is
yeah
hey maybe Tony's right that we should
explain how the algebra is constructed
but private that's not in the section
right because we've got to go on with
the C spec perfection no but I don't
think there's I mean when you connect an
external database that name can be
you
you
okay so okay entities
entity objects actually what we got to
say first is actually what we got to say
is built-in entity objects can be
specified with natural language using
this right because nothing else is going
to work with that right entity objects
can be associated with now what are we
going to say is it entity stores what do
we say here Tony which objects I mean we
don't even back reference entity store
here do we so I see two types of
categorization here one is a base entity
that is derived from a string type and
then there are these complex type
entities yes
constructor type and I would not really
make the distinction between built-in
and anti destroy entities because I
tried to make make it s transparent as
possible when it comes to it but the
whole point is that that's not going to
work right because for example there's
no linguistics for an entity store
entity right no right so that's the
answer or the type registered that is as
to can be other or another built-in
entity type or a type specified in an
entity store or what what's the
relational database version of that it's
the same we also use entity store okay n
entity of type common name okay that
seems like it's a clarifying remark okay
so now we've got to say this can
probably go further down because that's
true
all these cases right yes okay
in entity maybe a buff it should be new
in 11 it's a postal 12 okay you fix that
please um the computed class can be okay
so now well it's not just any of the
file
it's got to be something that returns a
single entity right how do you give the
name I don't understand how you give the
name in the case of um so in so this
form where does the name come from okay
this is a primary key for all of these
cloths it depends entity class shorter
than T class sample than T class
filtered entity class an extended NT
class it's the same name as the bay's
entity the last two are completed what
are they so for for a given C class it's
a list that corresponds to the third
argument of an identity class in
combined entity class is a list that
contains basically the clinical name of
the first argument and the canonical
name of the second okay we're gonna have
to make a table that actually specifies
this okay okay okay I gotta go um can we
try to get this set up within the next
two days so that we have not forgotten
what's going on but we need to review
first with Michael and I just I'm gonna
have to simply rewrite this I mean
simply add all this documentation so so
there's no no reason to do that okay um
just get a meeting with me as soon as
you can okay um okay see y'all soon all
right